ladies and gentlemen we have a great
show tonight
[Applause]
have a seat have a seat that is
this fan right here just keeps shooting
you with a Ghostbusters ray I don't know
how that's supposed to make you feel
good I don't understand anybody Peter
Capaldi thank you so much for being here
and entering with such a terrible
special effect I'm just good I travel
with my own dry ice things yeah very
nice I guess like some fog and clearly
ropes pulling pulling you in is this am
i correct this is your first comic-con
is that right my very first to call
McCall Wow tell us about it how is it
what's your experience been like well
everyone kept saying to me are you
nervous are you nervous making me more
nervous right at the day of the panel
approached and we were in there the
hotel for two days doing press and the
security people kept saying you can't go
out onto the street you can't go out
there because you'll get mobbed and I
was like come on guys put yourself in my
shoes you know I play this iconic
character wouldn't you walk down the
street yeah just like that kind Oh
exactly what you want to own it you're
Doctor Who get out there so you walk
down the street and like nobody comes
one little kid comes up and then
gradually another person comes in
another person comes before I know it
I'm done Italy a convention center yeah
at the lion you know and there were so
many wonderful people there I felt I
felt like running for office afterwards
yeah you know what's interesting is you
grew up a Doctor Who fan the show has
been on for you know 50 years you grew
up a Doctor Who fan now you are playing
Doctor Who
sometimes on the set you have to feel
like it's a dream almost a childhood
dream oh it's absolutely incredible man
as a child you know I wrote to Doctor
Who I got letters back from the original
Doctor Who's you know I drew pictures
and sent them to the BBC I got a letter
published in the equivalent TV Guide
thank how much what is really
embarrassing though is that now they dig
up all this stuff
and you know if you you don't really
want to hear what your fortune year-old
self has to say yeah about things but
especially if they don't explain you
wrote it as a 14-year old so I just
peter capaldi said me like Doctor Who
you know it's interesting different
actors take a different approach to
Doctor Who some people think that your
take has been to be a little more grumpy
yeah
fair to say yeah well he's two and a
half thousand years old he's been around
yeah and life is tough business as usual
yeah but he loves the great thing about
Doctor Who I think he's that is he's
actually full of joy because he loves
time and space and the universe you know
he can find beauty in the simplest of
things he can sit in the supermarket
carpark you know and watch the Sun
coming up and think that's the most
amazing thing or see stars being born in
Alpha Centauri he's made it's incredible
what's fascinating is it I remembered
over the years checking out the show the
special effects especially 2530 years
ago we're not that good but no one cared
they loved the characters so much that
they look beyond that that's probably
what we did here was almost on a par
with what was going on on dr. day thirty
years ago you know already at home
they're asking how did they do that in
the UK like oh my god but some of the
rules
somebody said to me when was the first
moment that you really felt like Doctor
Who and it was when they said you've got
to fight this giant spider and here it
is it's this big rubber spider and I
said right where's the operator and they
said there is no operator you just fight
it you just wiggle around with it this
is what I was born to be this is what I
was some doctor who's have developed a
bit of a catchphrase that fans get to
know is there pressure on you to come up
with a catchphrase really you know I
think I like to beat acetone yeah
taciturn that's not gonna catch on on a
t-shirt run anyway I like to be taciturn
no that's not gonna do it
we got to come up with one for you the
doctor is in you know I don't know Andy
anything we need something for the doc
anything I caught Andy not paying
attention
I was paying attention you were not I
was having a sip of tea
having some tea yeah that's the good
time to have tea yeah sorry
anyway we were just it's what I do here
we'll come up with one
fantastic
we know you're really very busy it was
such a thrill that you would surprise
our audience like this
[Music]
here Capaldi
learn apocalypse
[Applause]
[Music]